and so it's opportune timing that now we
have a man from the chess world who
wears many hats he is a part of he is
the president of the case yes but he's
also the Grantchester spokesperson and
that's what he's here to talk to us
about today very exciting news about
2019 grand test or from far-off chest
foundation to the grand Chester Michael
Court Akatsuki with Maurice with a dear
friend Mike cutter coughs key you know
Kasparov famously travels all around the
world wearing many hats doing lots of
things this guy one of his right-hand
compadres does the same thing I'm seeing
you in videos everywhere dude you're
also now one of the executive vice
president or one of the vice president
of fidei which I never thought was gonna
happen but at any rate you're gonna tell
us all of the internationai schooi was
going on at least I try to pull it out
of you but let's just start first of all
with this great announcement about the
grand chest tour all these players
except Kramnik accepting the invitation
to play the tour that must really have
warmed your heart yes absolutely
Ron Chester 2019 it's not only low
imagination of everyone with number of
tournaments that we brought up its
expansion of the ground shoe store up to
eight ordinates so we will we have to
classical events one in Zagreb Croatia a
new venue and obviously sinful Cup and
st. Louis as well as five a rapid and
blitz events which going to see there on
that list
amazing Paris and of course we had Paris
before but Ivory Coast aguar in Africa
which will be very cool to go to an Abba
John are you ready to go there oh man my
bags are already packed
and of course also Bucharest and
Calcutta being added to the tour as well
yes and actually we start with Abidjan
in Cote d'Ivoire it would be first leg
and we finish in Kolkata India as a
regular season and the finals as was in
2018 it would be in London the same
format as we had in 2018
this year though all participants
supposed to play to classical events
Zagreb and st. Louis and three out of
five rapid and bliss events
moreover we extend the number of
participants on the ground chest or from
9 to 12 so therefore all 12 players who
will be playing in classical events will
compete in three out of five repet and
bleeds to qualify for the finals so more
rounds instead of knock browns now it's
more rounds and classical events yes
more on some classical events the same
can participants
repeat on bleeds but this would allow us
to invite 14 wildcards so we will
increase field for other players down on
the rating list and of course we are
very very happy that in 2019 world
champion number one rated player Magnus
Carlsen returns back to ground Chester
and we'll be playing full tour in 2019
especially since it's not a World
Championship year where you have to play
a match so correct seeing all his his
noble competitors competing all year
round and all these amazing events and
he's got to sit back and watch on the
side must have kind of rubbed him the
wrong way and I'm looking at the names
of course you have Magnus Fabi mvo ding
Lauren Hikaru Nakamura Roni and Wesley
so young young the poem the Chi Sergei
car yaki onigiri and Viswanathan are
known again only the Kramnik because he
retired you
declining yes he actually knows
announced retirement however we're
hoping that what will participate in one
of the rabbit and bleeds as a wild card
so we well it's probably Paris I believe
because it's close to home where he
lives right now in Geneva but maybe in
some other places but we give him a few
weeks to three lakhs after making
retirement and he will come back to us
and will tell us whether he will be able
to play repeated leads any idea of the
other potential invites to we are going
to invite those who are be right below
on the your Universal rating system at
least right after Kuryakin because
Kuryakin took lots spot because what
retired and Kuryakin was invited and he
accepted this invitation as full tour
participant so whoever is down the least
you
rajab of greece shook they all will be
invited and will be invited you see
there 14 more 14 more yeah a lot of new
faces - yes we we also would like to
invite young generation of players like
do the Artemyev maybe do above time we
have won the world world yeah was the
world rapid championship yes yes year so
he have definite fighter absolutely and
do before one rapido sorry do but was
noble one wrap it and bleeds at the end
of the rapid one yes yes rapid and
artemyev one torment Gibraltar just
recently yes so therefore these two
young guns definitely will receive our
invitation for the young wants to show
yeah a lot of fun to see all this new
blood now so that's a
Ranchester and all this great news we're
very happy to hear that but we know
you're also a vice president of feed a
elected you told me you told me not just
not just donated this title what's
what's it the news now or feed a is
connected to this great tournament we
know that you also are doing some great
women's initiatives most famously
changing the world championship cycle to
include more money and reflect more what
the men are doing in the candidate cycle
well there are some changes within
feeder right now and there is new
Commission global strategy Planning
Commission led by Grandmaster Emil suit
offski and these Commission is working
on new regulations and bringing more
prestigious approach to high-level
tournament so they decided to change
regulations for women's chess in order
to make it more prestigious more
prominent if you will and by increasing
prize fund and also more visibility so
Emil is in charge of that therefore
first presidential board meeting which
took place in London is with 1 months
after election approved this and he's
supposed to work on that and one month
from now it would be second presidential
word meaning or first quarter of this
year presidential board meeting in
Astana in Kazakhstan in conjunction with
World Team Championship so some new
changes will be in effect over there
however there are many changes that new
feeder establishment is planning to
bring require approval of General
Assembly
therefore not everything could be
changed at once not everything could be
changed in the months two or three but
maybe in the year so let's see what when
they happen so give us some time
well now that you're inside this big
ship that is fee day I'm expecting to
see some changes I hope so but again
although I'm just one of many wise
presidents members of the few the
presidential board my heart is to
support us players and the u.s. shares
on that board final question this
tournament here
must really also warm your heart I know
you've coached a lot of youngsters and
you've coached even at a girls school in
New York still do and still do what is
it like to see this tournament happening
here in st. Louis no it's absolutely
great I mentioned that we started 15
years ago all-girls national in Chicago
2004 when we had less than 200
participants this year just in April
there will be already 16 addition to
that event and it's growing we planning
to break the record of 500 those who
come from more than 20 or 25 states to
participate at the national event there
are more regional and state girls
championships
therefore we build up already base we
build up possibility for best players
from junior level to go to the top level
and of course today I think it's a
celebration for women's chess that we
have here in st. Louis at Karen's cup
because right now junior players can
look forward to become one of those who
are playing here upstairs
and one day they will be at the board
and compete at the top level absolutely
we look forward to seeing that day as
there's a lot of great young players we
talked about Jennifer you and Carissa
yet Maggie Fang the names go on and on
we're just right there chopping at the
bit and this will be inspiring you know
thank you so much Michael very much for
everybody's what you do keep up the good
work
my pleasure thank you